liftoff for inspiration for blasting the
world's first all-civilian crew into
orbit
the spacex falcon 9 rocket took off from
florida on a three-day mission that will
take it
575 kilometers above the earth higher
even than the orbit of the international
space station on board businessman and
pilot jared isaacman who chartered the
rocket from spacex issacman has piloted
a variety of aircraft and will be at the
controls i just really felt at the time
inspiration four was created and knowing
that this was this was going to be a
first and there's a lot of
responsibility that comes with that that
you know we had to send a message that
there are real
real problems and real obligations we
have to pay attention to here on earth
in order to earn the right to make
progress for tomorrow the price tag for
the flight was not disclosed but
isaacman hopes to raise approximately
200 million dollars for saint jude's
children's hospital in memphis tennessee
he donated 100 million from his own
funds
isaac man also paid for a tv ad
promoting the mission that aired during
the super bowl
the chief medical officer on board will
be haley arsenau she is a physician's
assistant and recovered cancer patient
who was treated at saint jude's at age
29 she's the youngest u.s citizen in
orbit i'm really honored to be
representing kids with cancer and
childhood cancer survivors but you know
everyone in life has has been dealt a
certain hand everyone's had to overcome
something and i hope that those who are
in the process of overcoming something
can can look to me and see
the importance of holding on to hope
their fellow amateur astronauts include
sian proctor a geologist who barely
missed being selected as a nasa
astronaut in 2009
there have been three black female
astronauts that have made it to space
and knowing that i'm going to be the
fourth means that i have this
opportunity to not only
accomplish my dream but also inspire and
inspire the next generation of women of
color the fourth space traveler is chris
sembrowski an aerospace engineer at
defense contractor lockheed martin the
capsule's docking port has been replaced
for the occasion with a large
window-like transparent dome
inspiration four is the latest foray
into space tourism following sub-orbital
flights in july by billionaires richard
branson and amazon founder jeff bezos
spacex owned by yet another billionaire
elon musk is one of the leading
companies planning for a lucrative mass
market in space tourism over the coming
decades
rob reynolds al jazeera